what's the deal with airplane
peanuts amazing Rick Diaz on brand on
point well if I judge it by my laughs
per minute I think Hans Kim would have
gotten a run for his money tonight W
[__] [__] but I mean you're a golden
ticket winner you have you have a spot
on the show no matter what I feel like
you're protecting
[Applause]
him so are you still trying to protect H
Kim oh my
God oh my
God you literally are leaving the United
States of America next week yes sir and
you have one more Monday left in town
one more Monday to take a man's
job oh my god
oh you see that smile how would you like
it if someone came to your job was like
Hey I could do better at your job I
challenge you what is your official
prediction for what's going to happen in
your matchup against Hans Kim on New
Year's Eve oh I'm 100% beating his ass
in the 10-year history of kill Tony we
have never witnessed a story quite as
unbelievable as the story of Rick Diaz
who came to America for only 3 weeks
with the dream of being on this show not
only did Rick Diaz get his shot on stage
after his name was randomly pulled out
of a bucket containing hundreds of other
contestants but he also went on to
receive a standing ovation and the kill
Tony golden ticket after performing his
first 60 seconds of standup in the
United States he hasn't not set a punch
line it's
crazy everything he does is funny this
is a star but Rick Diaz did not stop
there in fact the craziest part of this
entire story is everything that's
transpired since Rick was given the
golden ticket on episode 628 oh man this
guy's dangerous dude I'm telling you I
know it when I see it oh what a defined
character you are since his debut
performance Rick Diaz has appeared on
every episode of kill Tony since and has
used the massive platform to publicly
call out one of the show's longest
running regulars Hans Kim there's no
inferring intent or reading between the
lines when it comes to Rick Diaz he
wants to replace Hans Kim as a regular
on kill Tony and is determined to make
that happen by any means
necessary There He Go oh
[__] and he is not smiling by the way
right oh my god
oh oh my God oh my God let me tell you
guys something all entertainment aside
Hans absolutely hates the fact that I
challenge him on his regular ship it
bothers him tremendously but he does see
the results week after week after week
of the pressure it's how diamonds are
created and here you go you have this
Rick Diaz who for two weeks in a row
keeps dropping your for no
[Laughter]
reason a guy that I invited into my home
he played Katan with me and my
girlfriend I did a podcast with him and
these are what Europeans are like don't
turn into this you are American you have
a backbone and a
spine this rivalry had been ramping up
quickly over the past few weeks until
now where It ultimately reached its
boiling point on episode 631 after Hans
and Rick finally confronted each other
on stage an Tony officially determined
they would fight for regular ship on New
Year's Eve in front of a soldout arena
in Austin Texas with the future of
beloved regular Hans Kim New Sensation
Rick Diaz and the entire kill Tony show
as a whole all hanging in the balance we
had to take a minute to talk to the man
that started this whole thing the one
and only sad man Rick Rick your onstage
Persona is very self-deprecating and
unsure of himself at times but you've
been super straightforward in calling
out Hans Kim on multiple occasions now
where does this confidence come from and
is it different than your confidence on
stage that's a very good question I
don't know where the confidence comes
from my Persona on stage is very
self-deprecating because I have an
agenda behind what I'm saying right so I
want to be self-deprecating and I want
to show that it's okay to make fun of
yourself and to not take your life too
seriously because we're just going to
die I'm a little bit of a nihilist you
know so I I really do believe that a lot
of things don't really matter that a lot
of things that we attach importance to
are just going to perish whether be
either before or after us and I think
that that can seem a little bit
depressing but it's actually giving me a
lot of confidence but once you accept
certain things in life the outcome
doesn't matter like if I'm on kill Tony
that's a bonus I wanton the lottery if
if I figure out that I can challenge H
Kim I mean I know he takes it personally
because he sees it as his job I see it
as it is a competitive world where we
all have to fight for anything and he's
been challenged numerous times and he's
won every single Challenge and he's got
more experience than me so for me it was
more about the experience of it you're a
kill Tony fan right of course yep so you
have seen every single or almost every
single previous golden ticket winner
right how many of them do you see
regularly on the show just you yeah
that's a good point so what's the value
of that golden ticket that especially as
a foreigner there are at least two or
three other golden ticket winners who
live in Austin right now that's
interesting okay we'll move on to our
our next question question cuz it kind
of plays into what you were just saying
is it true that Hans invited you over to
play Katan with him and his girlfriend
and do you feel any sense of betrayal
calling him out so many times after
starting like a friendship I had met
Hans Kim once for a podcast once in a
show and one set show and once when he
invited me over to play Katan and I
appreciated the gesture and I do still
want to be friends with him on the other
hand does that the fact that I go to
play Katan to his house mean I should
forgo any professional Ambitions I have
if I had asked him for permission before
challenging him and he had said no then
wouldn't I be a worse person for still
doing it yeah I'm not saying what I did
isn't selfish but I also feel like it's
not that to that unfair especially
challenging someone who again is filling
out theaters has been on the show for
over two years is doing great has a
great fan base he's a great comedian I
find him to be funny edgy and he's
pushing boundaries in what he's doing
and I don't want to take him out of the
Kil Tony family that's not the purpose I
don't want to not be friends with him I
don't want to discredit him but I feel
like I've been given a chance where I
was put in a position where I could do
this and I'd be an idiot not to do it
100% And I feel like from a fan watching
it seems like Tony might like this this
drama he's a fan of WWE wrestling it's
he always is drawing those comparisons
and as a fan it is very exciting to see
something that could actually affect the
show longterm playing out in real time
after you both walked off stage last
episode Tony said it's pretty much an
even matchup in his head but he does
give the slight Edge to Hans if it was a
betting matchup in Vegas how does that
make you feel makes me feel like it's a
completely logical conclusion he's got
eight years I've got four years he's in
his home turf I'm not it's got a huge
fan base I don't it's all if we if I had
to bet on who's going to win this I
would bet on hands no what I'm going to
do is write my ass off and perform to
the best of my abilities on that day in
those circumstances I've never played a
big arena you know like so I'm going
just going to do my best and then it
will be whatever it will be and you
notice that he's in his home turf like
you said and he's in this uh Arena or
theater setting like he he's used to do
you think the winner being choosen by
app pluse break helps or hurts you in
this matchup and has there been any talk
in changing how this voting system will
play out so far there's been zero talks
into how the system will be what I've
been told uh before I left Austin was
that it would be as any usual challenge
what I'm curious is which name will be
said second and whether there will be a
recount like let's say it now in the
other way round I think that would be
fair say it both ways and say and give
it two chances give two chances to the
crowd but that being said at the end of
the day it is a popular a popularity
contest it is a who's funniest on that
day contest it doesn't take anything
away from me believing I'm funny or or
being able to do other things with my
comedy or hans's you know capacity to be
funny and being incredibly successful
before after this so you're back in
Europe right now how has your recent run
on kill Tony affected your standup
career at home well on on some shows
I've been given a little bit more
freedom to come in and like drop in and
leave and not have to stay for the
entire show but that's that's about it I
guess a couple of clubs have called me
to do bigger shows that they may or may
not have uh included me either way I'm
going to open for a few people that have
noticed my growth thank to all of this
but they we already knew each other we
were already aware of each other it's
just maybe now it's like okay they're
asking for me a little more but I think
the next few weeks and months and New
Year's Eve we'll see the ramifications
of all of this later on it's going to
take months the way I see it is even if
I lose at New Year's Eve what I have to
do is do a good set have a good
interview and show that I can be funny
and then whether the crowd chooses him
or me at the end of the day what I want
is for the people that have anything to
say to be able to have a I'll be on a
huge platform and they'll be able to say
to say okay this guy's funny under
pressure and I think that no one can say
that you're not taking full advantage of
these great opportunities that you've
been given on Kil Tony which you've
definitely earned too I've seen you live
twice in Austin I was there a few weeks
ago and I got to see you I think on Tony
hinchliff and friends at the Vulcan and
then at the Sunset Strip as well and
it's hilarious to see you in person it's
hilarious to see you on kill Tony and
Hans is very funny too like you have
already mentioned so last question
before we go here what is your official
prediction for what's going to happen in
your matchup against Hans Kim on New
Year's Eve oh I'm 100% beating his ass
I'm taking revenge for when Korea beat
Spain in the World Cup years ago and it
was a complete unfair decision where
they stole they canceled goals it was a
completely unfair decision and I don't
care if I win by unfair Split Decision I
don't care how but I'm going to win this
I'd be an idiot to think any any any
other way the official battle for kill
Tony regular ship is going down in HB
Arena on New Year's Eve but just as a
preview of what we might be in store for
in a few months let's take a look at
both Hans Kim and Rick Diaz's set from
the last kill Tony and tell me in the
comments who you think would have won if
last week would have been the official
matchup thank you please
[Laughter]
laugh thank you
sir I was recently in Nashville and I
went to a museum and I learned that in
Nashville they used to have this thing
called The Negro building which I think
is horrible nowadays we just call it a
basketball
[Laughter]
court I don't understand these people
that are like don't get a tattoo or when
you're older it's going to look ugly who
are these people like man I might not
have had any fun when I was a kid but at
least I have this pristine 70-year-old
body I've never heard anyone be like man
I would totally [__] your grandma but
her tattoos are
[Laughter]
gross I have been buying a lot of things
through Instagram ads I bought that
purple stuff that's supposed to make
yellow teeth
whiter yeah I've been using it on my
skin
thank
you well well well it appears as though
we have created an Unstoppable
[Music]
monster all
right okay I've been trying to get rid
of my toxic
masculinity I really miss
Co I miss Co during coid people were
staying 6 feet away from me which was
closer than
before I wouldn't hurt a fly if I
tried I
tried yeah I don't does anybody here
have a sexual bucket list I can
help I don't have a sexual bucket list I
have a sexual
bucket and it's
full of
tears from H
Kim thank you very much I've been sad
man
Rick Rick
Diaz wow very defined style
uh again calling out Hans Kim I love
that you want to take his shot you
literally are a golden ticket winner you
get to be on the show anytime you want
but you would think that you would never
guess right I don't even live here
that's not he doesn't live here and he
literally wants to take Hans Kim's job
from him that's what foreigners do they
take Americans
[Applause]
[Music]
jobs this is going to be very close but
go ahead and drop your winner in the
comments of this video we're going to
count all these votes up and then
announce our our own favorite based on
audience response it would be awesome if
we could figure out how to actually
place bets on this matchup maybe that
will be possible by the time this
matchup actually happens with the help
from the sponsor of today's video my
bookie whether you're looking to bet on
football baseball hockey or anything
else you might be into my bookie is the
place to do it especially if you take
advantage of their 100% firsttime
deposit bonus which basically means
whatever amount of money you put in to
bet with the first time my bookie will
give you the same amount for free only
if you type in our promo code jkw rld D
there's so much action happening in
sports right now and if you're looking
to get in on the fun look no further
than my bookie for a reliable and easy
way to bet my favorite play this weekend
is under 44 A2 in the Colts Jags game
feel free to drop your locks in the
comments again that's promo code JK wrld
to claim your 100% cash bonus now back
to the video we weren't able to set up
an interview with Hans Kim for this
video but to give us a little bit of
insight into what might be going through
his head Hans had this to say about Rick
Diaz via Instagram not only is Dick's
comedy from the 80s so is the way he
sees other comedians this desperate
piece of Euro trash is so afraid he
isn't going to make it rightfully so
that he is willing to throw other
comedians under the bus so he can get on
stage and say nothing about himself he
is a single celled organism a cancer
cell and on New Year's Eve I will give
him a taste of American Healthcare Hans
how long have you been doing it 10 oh oh
[__] look how pissed he is some of you
might not be able to see it maybe you
need to know Hans a little bit better
like I do but that is his Furious face I
mean right now he's smiling but you're
going to see it's going to go right back
to it watch Rick say something say
something Rick say anything anything at
all
H it is important to note that Hans Kim
has been battling for his regular ship
against various Challengers now for
almost 4 months so it's not as if Rick
Diaz singled him out randomly as the
regular that he wants to go after no
matter who you're rooting for in this
matchup it is cool to see someone travel
all this way and grab an opportunity by
the balls like this and staying
determined to ride this momentum to the
absolute Highest Potential which at
worst will be performing standup in a
soldout Arena on New Year's Eve and that
best could mean becoming one of the new
faces of the number one live podcast in
the world thank you for watching this
video and please
subscribe at joke
World it
world and the world is wld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out